This has been my favorite late night snack lately.
I know it doesn't look the best,
but it's vanilla pudding with a raspberry sauce,
where you basically just make your vanilla pudding with your eggs, milk,
sugar, the usual,
and then
you make your raspberry sauce by boiling down some raspberries
with some sugar and lemon
and popping that in the fridge.
I like the combination of warm and cold stuff.
So my custard is a little warm still,
and then my raspberry sauce is cold.
There's just something about,
like, the tartness of the raspberries with
the sweetness of the vanilla pudding.
Hmm.
This is so good.
I grew up having vanilla pudding a lot,
so this is so nostalgic to me. Look at that.